joining us with reaction is former
senior counselor to president trump
kellyanne conway outkick founder clay
travis and fox news contributor charlie
hurt
kellyanne where to start there's so many
serious aspects to what was reported on
with what's going on at our border
and joe biden's in seattle on earth day
talking about electric tanks i don't
know how to i don't know how to square
that circle
well he went near the canadian border
anyway and
none of this makes any sense to anyone
in fact to go and talk and go all the
way to seattle roughly a 4 700 mile
round trip emitting enough carbon that
represents about eight americans carbon
output for the year through air force
one and then to not even memorize a
couple of good lines to not even be able
to be conversant or compelling or
persuasive or memorable joe biden talks
like that every single day for free
without going anywhere except walking
down for the residence in the white
house we didn't need him to go across
the country and by the way where is he
tonight he's going back for his 33rd
trip to delaware he has spent
25 percent of this presidency on
operation wilmington at home
that would be fine except why didn't he
just stop off in philly why didn't he
stop off in philly and say you know what
here in pennsylvania doesn't look like
it but you're you're living in a border
state fentanyl is the number one killer
18 to 44 year olds crime is on the rise
people are flooding into every state
roughly i was in atlanta last night with
newt gingrich he gave a speech and he
was saying it's basically in atlanta
every month coming over the border
roughly 7 000 people a day or so and so
any way you look at it this is a country
in crisis chaos crisis and a president
is not doing anything about it look at
the poll very quickly look at the polls
climate change and covid are now way
below
inflation immigration
education crime and of course national
security as as a top issue and so john
kerry just wants to be popular at davos
he wants to make sure that he's
lecturing the rest of us over his
furrowed brow and that he's popular
among the fashionable crowd
internationally joe biden continues to
confound me in this way he is not
meeting
the issues that americans are very
clearly telling every pollster that's
exactly the most important to them so
he's not even preaching he's not even
preaching to the choir he's talking in
the middle of a road to absolutely no
one with actually his back to the camera
which i thought was a perfect metaphor
joe biden turning his back on the
country it really
it really is clay
there are no other networks with
reporters actually asking questions at
the border when bill mallusion and
others do
honduran migrants say openly
i'm just waiting for may 23rd because on
may 23rd i know i got a free ticket
pete think about what we got going on
here the white house is still trying to
defend the idea that we all have to wear
masks on airplanes and while we walk
around in airports because of covid
while
simultaneously telling us that the
border they don't need to have coveted
emergencies anymore so title 42 can be
removed you can't make sense of that and
biden himself actually got asked about
it i know you saw it and everybody saw
it earlier this week and totally bungled
that response he confused the two and if
you watch the tape that you just played
from seattle this is unfortunate look
there was a lot of talk and i know
kellyanne heard it about the 25th
amendment surrounding donald trump joe
biden has dementia i don't understand
how you can watch him every single week
he's getting worse he's not making any
sense his speeches even when he's
reading directly off of a teleprompter
often don't make any sense the bizarre
whispering the turning the back who is
he talking to the shaking hands with
people that don't exist this is a guy
that is not in control i don't take any
joy in it because all of our enemies are
taking advantage of the fact that we
have an empty suit right now in the
white house and it's only going to get
worse over the next couple of years and
pete he's telling everybody at least
obama reportedly that he's going to run
for re-election at the age of 82. this
is madness he is in worse control of his
faculties than any president we've ever
had in modern american history this is
an embarrassment i don't know how we get
out of this mess but i know it's not
getting any better
there are some moments when playing the
what if it were trump game is quite
useful and if trump had done one tenth
of the things that joe biden is doing
now every cable pundit and other
channels would be yelling 25th amendment
there's just no doubt about it that's
that's not
uh that's not
conjecture that's what we know would be
happening but you mentioned the scary
part of the clay and that's why i want
to go to you charlie this is an ad this
has national security implications i
mean first of all the sovereignty of our
border and now you have the in chief
obsessing over electric vehicles
in our military and making sure we don't
emit because of climate change as
opposed to i don't know figuring out a
way to stare down the communist chinese
should that happen i mean when you look
at it through a national security lens
we look fundamentally unserious
oh and we are fundamentally unserious at
least uh joe biden certainly is uh and
you know one of the arguments that the
administration makes about the title 42
is that they're bound by law they have
to respect the the particulars of the
law that uh brought about title 42 in
the first place and they well my
goodness are you kidding me when did you
start caring about the law they ignore
the law every single day on the border
they refuse to enforce the laws that are
on the books that have been on the books
for decades they refuse to enforce any
of those laws so this idea that suddenly
they care about the particulars of the
law as clay points out at a time when
the administration on the other hand is
still trying to enforce coveted
regulations but of course everything is
political with these people everything
is lawless with these people and uh and
and and this display today
and if there's anybody in washington who
is as big a buffoon perhaps a bigger
buffoon than joe biden it's john kerry
and these are the two greatest foreign
policy experts washington has been able
to produce for going back at least 20
years and they have created every crisis
that we are facing right now and so many
of these crises are are caused or made
worse by this lunacy about uh windmills
and destroying our energy independence
that's why vladimir putin invaded
ukraine is because joe biden is in the
white house and because he ran off after
the you know
unicorns in fairy dust trying to
destroy america's energy independence
you're exactly right uh and yet
kellyanne as we talk about this there
are young
texas national guard soldiers trying to
do a job one of which jumped in the
river to save a migrant and
is missing at this moment and we pray
for him and his family but likely uh
won't end well
there are human consequences to this
there are indeed and in fact just
yesterday i was speaking to former
members of the border patrol former
members of dhs and and they all say the
same thing that never
unlike never before as sarah said we've
got border patrol agents doing doing
paperwork i mean they're just constantly
processing people handing out diapers
baby formulas trying to save lives
because we have a president of the
united states and commander-in-chief who
refuses to do what this nation has done
for decades for other countries to the
billions which is protect our own
borders we have protected the
sovereignty and defended the borders of
so many other nations over so many
number of years and we're not doing that
right here now people are watching this
and they know it do you know that in
most polling the number of americans
including suburban women including
self-identified independence pete who
care about immigration and border
security is higher than when donald
trump was there and he made this a
centerpiece of his campaign in this
white house why is that because they
know that there's nobody minding the
store now literally nobody in their
right mind minding the store and i just
want to make a quick correction i
understand that we all see joe biden
failing in front of us but i want him to
eat and own all of his policies i don't
want to make excuses for him uh because
then people think barack obama is
running the white house or kamala harris
isn't that bad this guy and the
democrats should be made to eat and own
all of the failing and the flailing so
that they walk into those midterms
elections in november and don't know
what hit them
clay uh and charlie we're almost out of
time i'll do 30 seconds each same
question do you think this white house
based on what kellyanne said understands
how disconnected the things they're
pursuing are from what people are
feeling clay
i feel like they are trying to
intentionally tank pete like this is a
situation right now i can't explain it
in any way it's like when you're trying
to get the number one pick in the nba or
the nfl and your team keeps
intentionally losing they are
incompetent on a level i've never seen
before that what's what feels like right
now
charlie incompetence or ideology that's
blind that blinds them or both no i
think no i think that they're just
completely seized by this ideological
craziness and they can't see anything
else and my one question is this you
know this week we saw jen saki burst
into tears talking about that law in
florida to stop people from teaching
kindergartners about transsexualism will
she cry for us over that texas national
guard that's what i want to know it's a
great question
it's a great question kellyanne
clay and charlie great panel thank you
all for being here appreciate it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else